sources tell ET Lamar Odom's family and
friends attempted an intervention with
him about his health but it failed just
weeks after the former NBA pro was
allegedly drunk and throwing up on a
plane a source close to Lamar tells ET
his loved ones are concerned about his
well-being quote Lamar is not in a right
place right now we're really worried the
source adds the 36 year old is not in
good company and calling any folds
friends no I saw it its park he's
getting rid of all the bad paper in
enemy yeah I mean I can't really take
the risk I'm seeing can't do do that to
that girl yeah well we got a she and
stayed by Lamar's side after he was
found unresponsive at a Nevada brothel
back in October Mary Jane easy honey
channel it's not your marriage wasn't
easy as ET previously reported Khloe
filed for divorce for a second time from
Odom in May citing irreconcilable
differences for the end of their
marriage now that Khloe is no longer in
the picture the source says he won't
listen to anyone he really needs help
but he doesn't want to accept any of it
et has reached out to Odin's family rep
for comment